I'm a little bit worried that the
mermaids are going to come out of the
sea and seek their revenge because I did
this one of the newest food trends on
Instagram is called mermaid toast you're
putting food dye on cream cheese and
spreading it on the toast and then
decorating it blue maybe green maybe
purple but if you get too many colors
you've made unicorn toast and that's
something totally different today I
decided to take on the challenge can you
mermaid it and I mermaid a pizza I'm
going to try I decided I needed to add
food coloring to the pizza dough it
turned out a little weird but ultimately
beautiful let's go with beautiful it's
going to be authentic mermaid pizza it's
got to have seaweed right so I added a
little seaweed salad different colors of
blue chocolate or the pepperoni
sprinkles edible glitter gold stars I'm
going to make somebody else try this Oh
My glob oh one burritos can you mermaid
them
can you put food coloring and rice yes
you can
can you put food coloring on beans yes
you absolutely can I'll have some blue
green and purple rice blue and green
beans roll that up a mermaid might eat
this if you look down on our luck at
like a mermaid gas station you can turn
any food into a mermaid food if you want
it badly enough you're eating your
regular bagel mermaid it immediately you
can mermaid this you can do pretty much
anything to a latte it basically just
tastes like a regular latte
we sludge in it could a s'more be better
mermaid style
can you mermaid it yes you can I think a
lot of people feel like they could have
a better life under the sea and who's to
say that they wouldn't hatch tagged
mermaid pizza hash tag do mermaids like
beans hash tag of course mermaids like
being hashtag mermaid beans